Speaker 1: All right, we're going to talk in this
segment about Democratic Senator Kirsten Cinema,
and we're going to talk about Democratic Senator
Joe Manchin. These will be two different stories,
each of them up to their own fair bit
of high jinks. Now, as you may know,
and as we've been talking about for some time,
it is not merely theoretical that Joe Manchin
and Kirsten Sinema may become obstacles to this
slimmest of majorities in the Senate for Democrats
to become legislation. It has become very, very
clear that both cinema and Manchin listen, whether
they enjoy it or not. That's speculation. I think
that they do, whether they enjoy it or not. They
are obstacles to Democrats getting things done.
And right now, what's in focus is Joe Biden's
build back better agenda as as it is called large
amounts of infrastructure spending, budgetary
issues and on and on and on. And these questions
as to whether Kirsten Cinema or Joe Manchin and or
Joe Manchin are going to support what is going on
here and increasingly they are getting in the way.
So let's first talk about Kirsten Cinema. Kirsten
Cinema was followed into a bathroom by activists
filming her during an event over the weekend, and
I'm going to give you I got a ton of questions
about this. David, what do you think? What do
you think about this? Is this OK? Is this not?
Let's talk about the story first. Watch the video
and then we will kind of decide. A video posted
to Twitter on Sunday by social justice group
Living United for Change in Arizona shows youth
organizers confronting Senator Kirsten Cinema,
even following her into a bathroom at one point
looking to talk to the Democratic representative
about her opposition to the build back better
agenda. President Biden's ambitious economic
recovery plan, widely supported by Democrats.
Several activists can be seen in the video waiting
outside what Lucia, that's the abbreviation
for the acronym for the group said was cinemas
classroom on Arizona State University's campus.
When cinema emerges, they asked to speak to her.
Actually, I'm heading out, she replies, and walks
into a bathroom stall over the sound of toilets.
Flushing, an activist identified as Blanca, spoke
to cinema from the entrance, saying, We have to
hold you accountable. In another video by Lucia,
the protesters follow cinema as she walks back
into her classroom. They said we wouldn't have
to resort to confronting cinema around Phenix
if she took meetings with the communities
that elected her. Cinemas communication director
declined to comment. Telling The Daily Beast
We are not dignifying this behavior with a
response, so let's take a look at the video. OK,
and let's listen. This is Senator Cinema heading
into the bathroom, followed in by activists.
Speaker 2: OK, I'll be back. So then
we want to talk to, you know, we I to.
Actually, I am heading out
Speaker 3: right now is a real
moment that our people need in order for us to
be able to talk about what's really happening.
Yeah, we need a build back better time right now.
Speaker 2: We will not fight with workers. We
need solutions. We can build back better
plan. We have the freedom that we need.
We knocked on doors for you to get
you elected and just how we got you
elected. We can get you out of office if
you don't support what you promised that
we need 70 million, 20 percent women. And
yet we need that. That mean times right now.
So now the toilets. My name is Blanca. I was
brought here to the United States when I was
three years old, and in 2010, my grandparents
woke unsupported because of an increase in 70s.
And I'm here because I definitely believe
that we need a pathway to citizenship.
My grandmother passed away two weeks ago and I
was not able to go to Mexico and visit him because
there is no pathway to citizenship. And if we have
the opportunity to pass it right now, then we need
to do it because there's millions of undocumented
people just like me who share the same story or
even worse, things that happen to them because
they're speaking 70. And because of anti-immigrant
legislation. And this is an opportunity to pass it
right now. And we need you to we need to hold you
accountable to where you told us what you promised
us that you were going to pass when we knocked on
doors for you. It's not right.
Unidentified:
I'm a survivor and a
Speaker 2: survivor
of human trafficking. And it's kind
Speaker 1: of been like a murder. OK,
so I think you generally understand
what what went down there. So, OK,
we've got our issues with Senator Cinema. Some are
saying, David, following someone into a bathroom,
it's bad. It's cringy. It's an absolute disaster.
The counterpoint that I've seen as she wasn't
really going to the bathroom, she was just going
to the bathroom because she assumed that she
would be able to get away from the activists. And
those were fake flushes. They were not necessary
flushes. I don't know the answer to that. OK, I
were. I come down on this is as follows. It's hard
to predict what kind of activism will get results.
And there's this common trope of trying to control
activism by saying this is off limits. That's off
limits. And so like, for example, sometimes when
people show up to the house of a senator, they
don't go in, they don't go on the lawn. They
don't go in the house. But they're on the sidewalk
with a loud speaker saying, Senator, whatever,
vote for this, vote for that. And there will be
people who say, No, that's that's over the line.
I don't want to be the one saying if we're not
breaking the law and we're not doing violence,
I'm not feeling super comfortable. Like I'm the
person to say what types of actors of activism
are OK or not. Because if we only ever did the
activism that's comfortable for those in power,
literally nothing would ever change. OK,
so I'm not making like a big statement
about what is and is not allowed because I
just don't think I need to. I'm not the there's
there's probably other people that are
willing to give you the list. My view is
I don't think this is going to achieve
anything. That's how I feel about this specific
incident. And basically, you know, my bill share
sarcastically tweeted yesterday, I think it was
alongside this video. We're definitely getting the
three point five trillion now. I just don't think
that this will work. And remember also that if
you were cinema, it's Arizonans who voted for you.
And as Bill Share also tweeted, Cinema
may be widely loathed on Twitter,
but not so in Arizona. The most recent Arizona
poll has her favorable unfavorable at 46 39.
Not amazing, but her net favorability is three
points higher than Mark Kelly. Also in Arizona,
and her unfavorability is four points lower.
Her unfavorability among Democrats is 19 points
higher, but favorable unfavorable with Democrats
is still a net positive now. You could make the
case well, but it's mostly Democrats who vote. So
it still leaves her liable to a primary challenge
challenger, right? Without a doubt. I mean, that's
that's absolutely fine. I think the point here is
even though there are conflicting polls and
she's loathed on Twitter, she probably has a
kind of OK popularity level among the people that
vote for her, which three years before reelection
is probably fine. So the idea that she's just
completely tanking in front of the people that
elected her doesn't really seem to be supported by
the numbers. The point is what she's been doing.
I hate it. I think that this is absolutely a
disaster. It's just not been a disaster to date
with her own constituents. And so is
it wrong to follow her into a bathroom?
I don't think it's going to work to actually
achieve anything is the way that I would say it.
I wouldn't follow people into a bathroom, and I
get that some are saying she just went in there
on that basis, the idea was that she could hide
out. Maybe. I don't know. I don't see this as
really changing anything, but I do agree
with myself from nine months ago saying this
mansion cinema stuff is really going to become a
problem. I want to talk about Joe Manchin next.